[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll talk about
your life
and your money that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five mariah is starting off
this hour in harrisburg pennsylvania hi
mariah how are you
i'm good dave how are you thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
so uh one thing that i really want to
celebrate
is i paid off my student loans um two
days ago
yay so yeah that's one big milestone of
my life
and i still have some debt left i still
have a car loan
and my parents have been gracious enough
towards me that they've allowed me to
stay at home
with them freeway they can allow me to
pay off my debt
so they've been really gracious with me
with that
so both my parents know how determined i
am to pay off my car loan too
and um i have left as
like that's what i have left so i'll
make it short for you um
so it's only fair to them
that i help them with utilities and
electric since i'm still living at home
and me and my mother have come to that
agreement
and that's perfectly acceptable because
i'm still living under their roof
um one thing i'm not comfortable with is
that
she wants to charge me rent which is
fair but
the stipend is that she will hold on to
that money for me
in her savings account and she won't let
me put that in my savings account
so i feel like there's a trust issue
there
per se like she doesn't trust me with my
own money
and she wants to help me out in a sense
of saving it for the future
but i'm 27 years old
27 what do you make a year
i make about 30 grand working two jobs
so i work 40 hours a week at my other
job and i put in about
20 hours with my part-time job so
you know i maria learning you're 27
you know my i'm kind of split so let me
say this on the flip side
my father did did the exact same thing
that
your mother is doing um but i was 20.
you know i was 19 20 maybe 21 around
that time
um he actually i i paid him 250 a month
and by the time i moved out he actually
gave that all back to me and some uh to
start my life
off but let me ask you a question i want
you to be honest with us
should your mom be able to trust you
like are you
being a good steward with your money
i am yeah she wants to play a game
where she's the landlord and at the end
of the game she gives me all that money
from
the the base rent that i've saved up
over
and i don't think that's so that i've
moved out so maria i think you gotta
look at that differently that's not a
game that's
i think that's your mother trying to
help you become a young adult and
if you've never paid rent before you you
do need to know how to do that
so i would definitely take the word game
out of it out of it out of your head
and say okay cool let me just pay my mom
rent move on about your life get out of
debt and do everything
and then just accept the fact that your
mom is just trying to help you mature
help you get ready for real life uh
because i'm pretty sure her rent is
nowhere near
what rent is actually going to be but i
would definitely say eventually
uh i would try out honestly if i was you
and dave may disagree with this
but at 27 i'm i'm looking at how do i
get out of the house even if i do have
some debt on the table yeah you need to
be gone you need to be gone in three
months
you're 20 you're 27 years old it's time
to move out
get get your job working get get your
budget on an apartment
figure out how it's going to work take
tell mom i got about three months to get
my act together the rest of the way
and um uh it's time for you to move out
you're
you're uh this is emotionally
treating someone like they're 18 17 19
years old or whatever and you're
27 yeah okay so yeah you need to move on
and your mom's trying to be sweet she's
trying to be helpful but it's time for
you to take that next big girl step
and uh it'll change your life it'll be
good for you it's gonna be really hard
and it's going to be really good for you
open phones at
825-5225 thanks for joining us america
we're with you we're here to help george
is with us
in cincinnati hi george how are you
i'm good how are you sir better than i
deserve what's up
i appreciate you taking my call just
wanted to uh
ask your advice on buying some land
right now to build a house
so currently my wife and i are on baby
step
six so we're attacking our house now and
uh
we have about three hundred thousand
still uh
to pay off um for our mortgage how
quickly are you gonna build everything
else
well that's the question my wife thinks
it's better to buy a lot right now
and just kind of wait kind of see how
things go for the next six months or so
and
i i thought it might be but that would
be a good idea but also maybe we
do the construction a permanent loan for
a better rate
so we don't have you know i would just
you know if i was going to buy land i
would
buy a piece of ground in the
construction loan and start building
if you're not gonna and that's just
that's just the answering the question
can i move and the answer is yes you're
gonna move
but do i do you start investing in land
or do you buy land where that you might
use 10 years from now
and not pay cash for it no i would not
but if it's a part of making an
immediate move and you're going to start
building very quickly
then yeah i would go ahead and and start
that process and then of course your
home goes on the market and sales and
you
uh you move into the new property that's
being built
by the new builder on the new piece of
ground whether it's a piece of land or
a simple lot in a subdivision either one
of those is fine but
but this thing of uh oh i'd like someday
to maybe move so i'm gonna just go buy a
lot no i wouldn't do that that that very
seldom you very sort of end up building
on that lot
no you're absolutely right and george i
put my business out there me and dave
talked about this about last year and
dave was like
nah not not unless you're going to move
anthony if you're not going to move then
uh don't do it and thankfully his wisdom
was correct
because i didn't build in that that area
actually went totally opposite
of where i thought i was going to go so
i want to echo what dave is saying
if you know you're going to move there
and start the building process do it now
but if it's down the road
things could change life could happen so
i would avoid that at all costs
yeah they will change yeah that's how
that'll work open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
just to recap if you're building a home
there's three pieces of paper that are
really important
you need a budget that you and the
builder are in agreement on
and it's line by line you know what each
of the categories in the budget look
like just like i'm just like running a
budget for a business or for your
personal life same thing
you need a schedule what's going to be
done
when not just what's the delivery date
but
the framing is going to be this day the
trim carpenter is going to be this day
kitchen cabinets will be installed
on this date you need a schedule and you
need a blueprint
and that tells you what's being built
and you manage to
the schedule the budget and the
blueprint this is project
management if you cannot do that with
your builder
you have the wrong builder this is the
dave ramsey show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america anthony
o'neil ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five william
is with us in pensacola florida hi
william how are you
doing fantastic sir thank you for asking
sure how about yourself
uh yes uh so i had a quick question for
you uh much
dissimilar um as the same caller
in her living situation after taxes i
don't make much more than minimum wage
and i've been carrying the car loan that
i have now for
a little over two years my question was
is it
worth refinancing the vehicle uh to try
and free up some extra money so
i can afford a place to live by myself
and not live with my parents anymore
or what's the best course of action
how much do you own your car yeah
what is that how much do you owe on your
car
i have 13 000 left what kind of car is
it will you
it's a 2017 ford focus
okay um and how old are you
i'm 26 in march okay and
why um tell me about your career because
it sounds like you have an income
problem
yes sir i don't have much of a career at
the moment i fell on some hard times
and troubled upbringing so i'm just
really just trying to overcome a lot of
that and start making
my own efforts to to get into a career
now
what what what's preventing you from
getting a solid job
i know you said hard times but like
without saying too much of the personal
information what's what's preventing you
from getting
a good quality job
uh probably experience okay do you have
any education
i've self-taught so it's not viewed the
same
but i have enough of a generalized
understanding
and what are you doing probably take
what are you doing right now william for
a career
i'm working in a college uh basically
integrated
okay okay all right um here's my thing
i agree with dave you have an income
problem and you're young
and so uh i think right now until you
can land a solid career and i want to
connect you with our career expert ken
coleman
but before you go over there there are
two practical things you could be doing
right now you have a 2017
car quality car and just the other day
on the show we found
uh dr john delonay and ourselves met a
young man your age
making about six thousand dollars a
month just off of delivering
for ubereats and for just doing uber
period
and so your income problem could be
fixed
if you're willing to really put into
work and so if i was you with a 2017 car
right now
immediately when i hang up the phone i'm
registering with uber
you're in florida which is wide open i
will start driving people around on top
of what you're doing
then get connected with ken coleman to
figure out what is your sweet spot how
can you get into a career
that will set you up to win but right
now you don't even have the money to
move out with your parents you got 13
000
in debt so we need to get your income up
and then your first priority yes
is to get out on your own and then we
need to talk about how do we get you out
of this debt and don't rack up any more
debt but today
immediately william i need you to kind
of like
say this respectfully step up it's time
for you to become the young man that you
are
and going ahead get on an uber find you
something you can do today that can
start generating you an extra five
thousand dollars a week immediately
yeah um i don't know what you've been
facing with your hard times i can't i
you know obviously we don't have that
information but uh the answer to your
question
is you only owe 13 000 on the car
if you told me it was 33 000 and you're
making minimum wage i would have said
just sell the car
yeah this is selling this car does not
fix your situation because it's not
really your problem
the fact that it's pinching you is
indic is because of your income
more than it's because of the debt or
the size of the car payment
that kind of a thing and so yeah your
issue is career short term and long term
and we've got to get your income up
short term and anthony outlined that for
you and then long term so
hang on and um kelly will pick up and
we'll get you hooked up with
a ken coleman book the proximity
principal and she can also
set you on his website and help you with
some of the uh
some of the interview techniques and
some of the things that he's teaching
which are absolutely fabulous
dave you're a father and i just got to
ask you this question because i'm seeing
this more and more with this younger
generation
they're at home they don't have a good
job
and i feel as if part of that is and a
huge part of that is on
the the young man or the young lady but
would you agree or disagree with me that
a huge part of that also is on the
parent
you're allowing your son or daughter to
come home to be 26 27 30 years old
making 30 000 a year like how is that
advancing them forward
well it yeah i mean mom and dad's
attitude
about the whole thing affects uh the
young person's attitude as well
so if mom and dad are like well you know
pandemic and it's bad
out there and there's no jobs and
you know they got a negative attitude
about everything they don't see any
positive way to go make money um and you
know oh you can't do uber because you
know
you can't be socially distanced or you
can't have enough masks on or
whatever i don't i don't know what it is
i mean but if mom and dad are saying
well i mean you're screwed you can't do
anything so you might as well live at
home
instead of saying uh you step up man up
here and let's get going which is what
you did
to with this guy and and so it's um
you know i grew up one of the blessings
of the household i grew up in was mom
and dad were entrepreneurial
and so if um if you didn't have any
money it's just because
you didn't have any ideas and you
weren't working so you need an idea
and you get to work on it because
there's always a way to make money
i mean you can walk dogs you can mow
lawns you can clean out gutters you can
pressure wash driveways you can you know
i mean
teenage jobs i have done i've shoveled
out stuff out of houses i don't even
want to think about yeah and so i mean
there's all you know
it's there's and you'd be amazed what
people will pay you to do if you will
bother go get you a leaf blower rich
people are afraid of leaves you know
i mean it's it's uh you know there's a
lot of stuff that people can do but but
mom and dad my parents had that
entrepreneurial spirit and so we weren't
a we weren't allowed to not work yes and
b we weren't allowed to not be
dreaming about a better life while we
were working
that's good and instead of just like
well the little man can't get ahead
you're just stuck the pandemics got you
in
this generation here you just can't get
anything and you're just
bad now god man when i was your age
there's lots of opportunities you guys
ain't got any opportunities there's
nothing out there to do
good lord with technology right now you
can start about six businesses by
nightfall
yes yes yes yes and when i hear that
dave i i get so frustrated and i have to
ask you because
well i think most parents are between
you know they're between hard driving
entrepreneurs like mine were
and you know eeyore that i just painted
up right so
they're somewhere between and but i
think the thing mom and dad can do is
speak
life over the situation speak blessings
over the situation
and it's not false encouragement or
false positive thinking or something
like that
that you just dream up it's just really
believing that if you
you know you get out there and you push
things around something will fall over
yeah but i'll guarantee you it won't
while you're sitting there wishing it
was going to
yeah yeah parents we got to do better i
mean i'm not a parent so i can't speak
to
parent as a parent but i would
definitely say i i am
concerned uh with this generation
a small portion of this generation and i
get it covet happened
covet was real jobs were real but dave
i've seen so many young people got
creative they went online
they started online tutoring they went
out there starting cutting people's
grass because they were scared to go
outside
and just last week me and john was so
shocked on friday
uh this young kid 28 years old said man
yeah i made six thousand
dollars just from doing uber driving
people around and i'm like wow and
people are saying there's there's no way
to make money right now and there is if
you're willing to put into work
you will do it we want you safe we're
not saying do not be safe
but at the same time when you step up
and say you know what i'm going to take
control over my future
and i'm going to become better every
single day and you can
yeah well and it's you know lou holt's
our buddies 83 and
what he said when he was down here last
summer speaking he said uh
please don't keep me alive by stopping
me from living
yes he did yes he did something to think
about
[Music]
yes
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same time financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option and the
original health cost sharing ministry
for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage
ferg and chelsea are with us hey guys
how are you hey
you're doing great welcome you guys
where do you all live tulsa oklahoma
well welcome to nashville and all the
way over here to do a debt-free scream
heck yes i love it love it love it how
much of you guys paid off
we have paid off 147 268.79
love it how long did this take three
years 10 months and eight days
three years and 10 months and eight days
man and your range of income
during that three years and ten months
uh mid thirties
to uh 122 000. goodness that was a bit
of a jump
yeah yeah well tell us your story what
happened and how'd that income go up so
fast
well uh we got married about five years
ago in may
yeah um then we had some some family
stuff
happen uh sorry already happening
um just some family drama um
some some uh
disagreements when it comes to money
including family drama
and we're like all right lord we need to
figure out what we're doing
we jumped into a church high church on
the move family
appreciate you guys um and we got
invited to
be a part of a fpu group like right
after like a month or two
after moving back to tulsa and
we jumped in and we haven't had any
money fights
yeah since we jumped in so we got on the
same page and
that's what started the journey um so
some of the drama was between you two
not not completely not really i know it
wasn't all of it but
no it was it was we got married in in
may and
it was like a whirlwind um i graduated
from grad school
the same month we and then i moved out
here he was not out here i moved out to
tulsa
oklahoma and he was already living there
so it was a big jump for me
to join him there and um i just got my
degree so it's like the next steps and
getting licensed and everything so
what's your grad school what's your grad
work in
um we both have a mental health
therapist backgrounds
okay so great yeah so i was working on
so that's the jump in income
yeah you both both got into your career
it's really minded too i was already a
therapist at the time
uh but um it was a community-based job
which is you're driving around
to your clients and it's it was
basically work based like what
you bill is what you get paid from and
as a single dude
that really wasn't gazelle intense on
his debt he's like okay i'll just pay
off debt as i can but i'm not
really going after it or anything like
that so and she when she moved out
um and we jumped into fpu it was like
okay we need to
really look at and i was praying okay
god how do we get a bigger shovel
because he keeps talking about getting a
bigger shovel
i have no idea what to do with that and
on the emotional side of things
um you know we're also just trying to
stay afloat
you know mentally emotionally because of
some of the stuff that was going on
yeah well it sounds like your church was
a real lifeline yeah
absolutely they if it wasn't for that
god totally lined up all of the steps
there because
our first week together there we were
like
we want to find a church and we had both
had previous experiences there so we
went and there was another couple that
the lord had waiting for us there to
pray with us about finding a home
and um and they were like hey we're
we're on the same age we're in the same
situation as you for the most part and
let's like partner together and would
you guys like to come to fpu
fpu with us uh we're going to lead that
starting tomorrow night
wow yeah yeah so it was a real quick
turnaround of hey
okay we didn't plan to do that but that
sounds like a good idea this is right
after a conversation we had the night
before about okay we gotta figure out
what we're doing with money because
we're not on the same page as far as
grocery bills and how much we're
spending on groceries and we don't know
how to budget together yeah
and so this whole brand new marriage
thing yeah absolutely the 147 that you
all had
i'm assuming that it was student loans
majority of them yeah
there was like 3 000 that was taxes from
a year or two ago
okay so we just threw that in the
snowball so with your age bracket
because we're in the same age where i
could hear and uh i'm always
i'm always curious to ask young people
what what was the hardest thing
on this journey and to the millions of
young people listening to us right now
what do you say is the one key
ingredient to really
changing around your financial life i
would say the hardest part
is not getting discouraged
when you know you are doing something
with purpose
um every step every day that goes by is
not a wasted day so the
the hardest part is you're not going to
know anybody else
most likely that's doing what you're
doing um
and so and and we had the most debt even
in our fpu group and so we were kind of
the only ones
still even with that group that were
really going through it as long as we
were
you have no idea like we're sitting
there on that first it's like the first
or second week of fpu and it's like
this is what the total debt is for the
whole group yeah and we like tripled
everybody else's
yeah and we're like oh lord and we were
so embarrassed for a second but then it
was also like okay no it's okay it's
okay we can just have the best
story out of the whole thing
[Music]
having a testimony is a good thing
getting one's a pain in the butt yes
well well done you guys well done to
answer your question though about
like what was the thing that really
helped us get us through honestly it was
jesus jesus
yeah it was totally jesus i mean every
step yeah was like there was this next
step for us
it's like hey you know we know that
you're going through some stuff with
some family and some family issues
but here's here's a lifeline whether it
be our small group thanks guys we really
appreciate you we really love you
whether it be our employers empowered
life
alisa charles thank you so much for the
opportunity uh
preferred family health care in
dayspring thank you guys so much you
know we got to negotiate for a raise
we got a raise it's also sunshine center
it's where i work and
actually during the 2020 pandemic
everybody you know had to go home
and it was kind of one of those loosely
held hey we don't know what to do but
maybe if you guys can try to get some
you know some telehealth going go for it
so that was we were so close to the end
this past summer and i was just like
well we're so close we don't want to
slow down our getting out of debt
and all of the interest payments halted
and everything with all the student
loans so we were like
what can we do so um i started getting
all of my clients to tell health really
quickly it was the first
one of the first ones i think it was the
first one in the whole company
that got as many telehealth sessions
going
as quickly as i did so instead of
finding an excuse not to work you were
desperate to work oh she crushed it yeah
and because of that there was an
unforeseen
blessing that came from that because a
few months later the owner was like hey
guys
you know we're going to offer this bonus
basically for whoever can bring in the
most income for the company during this
this time and i got the bonus and that's
what put us over the edge
i love it yeah that was a really good
feeling like we're gonna we're gonna pay
off the last loan with this bonus
yeah because we were doing some gazelle
intense stuff so now you've been through
three years and ten months and eight
days
of real transformation yeah
i mean there's a lot has gone on in your
life during this time money's a piece of
it there's a lot has gone on yeah
was it worth it i would never want to
live it again but i would never want to
have lived without it
without that that journey yeah one of
the things about
our like our bible verse comes out of
james where it talks about
when you have persevered through all of
these tests you will receive the crown
of life that god has promised
and like my family we have a scottish
background and our
motto is sweetness out of difficulties
and it was like yes we just really
leaned into that who better for it yeah
who better for it we're gonna jump in on
this and we've
we have grown closer we've communicated
better yeah
um through all this stuff and it's just
really awesome to have somebody
kind of you know in your corner um
fighting with you tag teaming with you
that's like
we're we're heading in the same
direction and we're on the same goal
way to go well we've got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires that's definitely the next
chapter in your story
you guys are incredible it's an honor to
speak with you and thank you for making
the trip all the way over from tulsa to
do your debt-free scream thank you
well done all right it's ferg and
chelsea they paid off 147
000 in three years 10 months and eight
days making 30 up to 122.
count it down let's hear a free scream
ready
three two one
that's what three years and ten months
sounds like right there man
we did this in in 14 days this is three
years and 10 months and eight days
man they are persevering people they
scratched and clawed and scrapped
so proud of you guys absolutely very
well done so proud of you
wow amazing this is the dave ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one
online retailer of custom window
coverings
you got free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more dave our question
comes from deidra in tennessee my
husband and i had 16
000 student loans when he graduated two
years ago
and now we only have eight thousand
dollars left i love it we have been
paying even during the moratorium to pay
down the principal
so we are ahead of payments by quite a
bit
awesome we are reading in the news that
congress might write off ten thousand
dollars of everyone's student loan debt
should we keep paying to take advantage
of the no interest
at this time or stop paying and wait to
see
uh what they will do if you're going to
wait to see
if the congress is going to do something
you are going to be disappointed
uh i'm not saying 100 guarantee it won't
happen but here's the thing
uh in my history i've never seen it so
if i was in your shoes
i'm paying it off i'm not stopping i'm
not waiting for the congress
you if you wait on washington to fix
your life your life's always going to
suck
this is a good rule so i don't know
what's going to happen with this
i mean um i have no idea there's no way
of knowing i was pretty sure
a few months ago but the political
climate has shifted
and uh the power structure has shifted
and so
it's possible that they run this through
i don't know
i never dreamed i would see it in my
lifetime but i've seen a whole lot of
stuff in my lifetime i never dreamed i
would see
my life right so um
i i i don't
um yeah i if i were in your shears i
agree i
because i'm not gonna wait to fix my
life on
washington to save me right and so it's
um
it's just a bad plan and again they may
turn around by
the end of summer and you may go i hate
dave ramsey just cost me 10 grand
um and i hate anthony o'neil
oh yeah but you have to be on the same
list i mean this is real i mean
that's this this is my suggestion well i
was agreeing with you
okay either way pay it off dude yeah
listen folks i'm
i'm always going to tell you pay off
your loans yeah all right we're just
always going to tell you
take you have to control the
controllables let me tell you what you
can't control
congress you can't control the president
and you can what you can control is
paying off the loan so control the
controllables and build you a life
and that's your best plan so now let me
ask you this question dave i think i
know your answer but it's fair to ask it
so what if they just say you know what
since there's no interest what if i just
put that money to the side for the next
four months while there is no interest
i'm just not gonna try to game the
system
right gotcha every time people try to
game stuff
is when they get screwed and it's when
it doesn't work out for them
and so what let me tell you what would
happen some percentage of the time
we throw ten thousand dollars in an
account we're sitting around waiting
we really hadn't been aggressive by
paying off student loan we let our foot
off the gas we're not really budgeting
tight
and man i sure did need that bass boat
go buy the bass boat congress says you
know what we can't get that student loan
thing through and you're still sitting
there
staring at a dad gum paid for bass boat
right with your money you should have
used to pay off your student loan
this is what happens then you end up in
coaching one of our coaching offices
somewhere and people are going you did
what
and you're going yeah i know i was so
stupid and we all have these
moments where we did something but it
always comes around trying to scam
trying to scheme trying to
trying to run the system somehow i'm
going to run the system i'm gonna i'm
gonna beat the system
and don't beat the system pay off your
debt yeah
just don't you know there's no shortcut
to any place that's worth going
abby's in madison wisconsin hi abby how
are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm a 21 year old college student
about to graduate in the spring
congratulations what's your degree in
fisheries and water resources cool
um so long story short i'll be getting
an inheritance of about 150
000 um i'm on baby step two
and i only have about twenty four
thousand dollars
on student loans is my only debt
which i'm planning to pay off with that
inheritance
good as well as say that three to six
month emergency fund
good but my question is what should i do
i want to invest the rest or at least
part of it
what would be the best plan for that
i would just sit down with one of our
smartvestor pros and start
learning about some of the mutual funds
it
may be uh i'm gonna guess and say some
of that the balance of that money after
the debt is paid and the emergency
fund's in place
that um in the next two or three four
years you're probably going to be
in a situation where you buy a home yeah
and that you've gotten started on your
career you've gotten your income up
you're doing good
and you know we're going to move from
rental to home ownership at some point
you know
like 25 years old or whatever and you
may use that money to do that with
and so uh you need to it doesn't need to
be invested in something
volatile it needs to be invested in
something kind of boring and steady
so even like what's called an s p 500
index fund might be good for that
shorter term
down payment investment because i'm kind
of calling this down payment money right
now in my head listening to you
yeah but sit down with the smartbuster
pro click smart vester
at daveramsey.com it'll drop down a list
of the smartvestor pros in your area
they'll
teach you and you need to learn you
don't need to do it because anthony said
do it and you don't need to do it
because i said do it you do it because
you understand it
and you're investing and you're being
careful and wise and you know what
you're doing
and someone with the heart of a teacher
like one of these smart mr pros has led
you through the process
yeah yeah great advice dave i haven't
had to it that was beautiful
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you feel like
you will never save enough money or pay
off all your debt after a year like 2020
sometimes people feel the same way it
was kind of a hope
stealing year wasn't it money should not
be
one more thing that you have to worry
about that's why for 2021 we're hitting
reset because no matter what's happening
in the world you can
take control of your money you just need
the right plan ramsey plus is our
step-by-step plan where you get quick
wins
and that means you can finally start
spending and saving your money without
worry
and get the security that you need
ramsey plus includes of course financial
peace university
the every dollar budgeting app the
premier version and
many many many other tools it is chock
full
and they will show you step by step day
by day week by week what to do for the
first 90 days and get you a
quick start and you will never be out of
control again you can do a
free uh trial at ramsey plus just go to
daveramsey.com
reset tanya is with us in hartford
connecticut hi tanya welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
i am 45 years old and i'm currently on
baby step 6
so i'm looking to pay off my home by the
fall of 2022
this will be about six months before my
oldest graduate high school
and i really have to thank financial
peace university for helping me with
this journey as i became
really gazelle intense since 2017.
cool so before covet
this goal was reality however with covid
and the additional income i would
normally generate
it would be now an additional year
before i could accomplish this goal
so my concern is that i have another son
who will be graduating after my oldest
so i'll have two back to back in college
ouch so i'm looking yes i'm looking for
um
ways to for me to meet this goal so i am
considering lowering my 401
k my roth contribution to do so maybe
withholding it
temporarily i also face some medical
bills that weren't anticipated
um during the past year that i had to
take care of so right now i am putting
about two thousand dollars more a month
towards the principal
but realistically i'll need another 900
a month to get the house paid off in
that time
so should i hold off and contributing to
my 401k to be able to accomplish this
you have outstanding debt right now on
medical
um it's only about probably about
five hundred dollars more okay so you
can knock that out like this month
uh yes but you're not paying any extra
on your house while you have that
um i love then
clear your debts you're back in baby
step two
you gotta clear those debts do you have
an emergency fund
oh absolutely
okay you should have just written a
check out of that and paid your medical
that's what it's for but anyway we clear
the medical
um would i stop my
ira temporarily to get the house paid
off to cash flow college
might might in this case for a very
short period of time
it's really stopping the baby steps is
what we're doing you're changing them
and hold on we're going to send you a
copy anthony's book debt-free degree
because they need to be working to help
get to college yes
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of
bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host anthony o'neil
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book that
free degree
is my co-host today open phones as we
talk to you
about your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two
five kayla is with us in provo utah hi
kayla how are you
hi good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
um so i just had a question my husband
and i are getting ready to save up for a
down payment on our first house
we make roughly 60 to 65 000 a year
when i plugged it into your calculator
online it said that
with a 40 down payment we could afford
about a 280
home however where we are at there's
really no homes that start until about
300
000. and i was wondering what are your
suggestions for us as we're trying to
save for our first house
well i think to say that there are no
homes in provo utah
below 300 000 would be an inaccurate
statement
we are more in rural utah um provo's
kind of our closest
big city um so when i looked at what
i've been looking just for the past
while just for fun
and it looks like the ones that are
around 250 kind of more our price range
or more like your trailer homes and
whatnot
okay i think you've just begun your
quest
you uh you're in the early stages of
gathering information
so um yeah the uh uh
i know and and i'm i do not know that
market uh extremely well in the sense
that i can just quote numbers to you on
what they're worth
the average home price in america is 225
000 right and that does not trailer
homes
okay that's the average in america and
the average household income in america
is 59 000.
so that's right where you are i mean
that's um
you know you're you're 60 000 income and
you're looking at a 250 000
house give or take uh up to about a 300.
so i think you're just on the pro
at the beginning stage of the process
and generally uh
for your first home what you're doing is
you're looking for a starter home you're
not looking for
a mansion and um
and so i think you're gonna keep
scratching and digging and looking at a
lot of properties and it may take you a
little while to find the deal that does
fit your numbers
but here's the thing you cannot get in
the business
anywhere in your money situation of
saying oh
well it costs that much and i don't have
that much
so i'm going to do it anyway because
math doesn't really count
in my situation math counts in every
situation math works in california
it works in utah and it works in new
york city
uh it even works in tokyo and one of the
most expensive real estate markets in
the world and you can't afford to live
there
so um not even rent with your income so
the the you just don't get a pass on
math because of your situation so
you're either going to watch your
incomes come up or you're going to find
a bargain
and you're going to shop around and
learn a little bit more the interesting
thing about real estate is
is that there's always another one yes
yes yeah yeah and one thing i'm going to
say on this one too dave
let's just say that it's the case you
cannot find a house
within your budget then that means
you're not getting a house right now
until you can find one that's in your
budget and there's nothing wrong with
renting until you either get your income
up or until you find a house that is
within
your means well and you again
real estate is that's the most fun about
the real estate business is there's
always something
yeah you just keep scratching around
turning over rocks something will run
out
foreclosure something yeah something
that needs a little paint a little work
and
you know your father-in-law your husband
jump in there and you jump in there and
you put a
paint brush on on those i don't know
yeah but you know there's a lot of ways
to to get at this
and um uh uh but just to go well
you know it's just too expensive and so
math doesn't count math counts
yeah man you don't get a pass on it hope
that helps open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five ryan's in green bay
wisconsin hey ryan what's up
hey dave i just got a question um so my
girlfriend's uh
currently in college uh going to be a pa
and i finally introduced her to dave
yourself um
about paying off college and all that
but i currently
have no debt or nothing i just bought a
house in september
and i'm thinking because i this is the
girl i'm gonna marry
because i've dated her for six years
freshman year in high school
it's just i'm not gonna pay anything
until we're married like you say
but do i save to pay that off or do i
add
more the extra money to my home loan
right now
all right man ryan let me help you out
here dave may give you a different thing
talk tim
how old are you right i'm 21.
how old is your girlfriend she's 21 as
well
well y'all young all right so i don't i
like how you're thinking about the
future but i want you to stay
with you right now all right um and so
my thing
is i want you to work the baby steps for
you don't stop the baby steps for a
potential down the road
all right and i'm telling you that
because i wish somebody would have told
me that when i was your age at 21 years
old
um i hear your heart for this young lady
i pray that y'all do get married
and have all the dreams that you desire
but there is a strong possibility that
it may not work
all right so what i want you to do is
attack the baby steps for yourself
so if you're paying off you know things
on your end you do that
okay and then wait down the road for
them it's good advice anthony let me ask
you this if if
when he gets engaged would you change
that uh
it gets engaged will i change that no
that's just me personally
but you wouldn't say about money to pay
off the the coming debt from the bride
no i would you would yeah because
when you have a date when you're engaged
it's your fiance and you have a date
set and you say she's got 60 000 worth
of debt i'm gonna pile up cash to get
ready
during that six or eight months or
whatever before we get married now i'm
not talking about vague engagement that
we may get married someday and we just
call it my fiance and
we really are just not even you know i'm
talking about a set
wedding date and you know within within
a reasonable period of time and i'm
going to get ready for that so when we
come home from the honeymoon because
we've often told grooms to pile up or
gr or brides to pile up cash to pay for
the wedding
well and and to pay upon coming home
from the honeymoon pay off her debt
or or pay on her debt here's the only
reason why i would say no
but i'm wrong with you i understand what
you're saying only because this
generation
they say yesterday and then they're
they're done tomorrow and they
paused their whole life for well then
you would take the cash and throw it at
the house
exactly that's why i said i'm rocking
with you yeah but if there's an
engagement i would not do it at this
stage gotcha like
in his mind it's inevitable uh she ain't
said yes
yeah so not an even after she has it's
not inevitable right
so there we go but yeah you're that's
your point all the young people out
there looking at me like i actually
agree with you anthony
we're taking a poll from the studio
audience and anthony wins
okay open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money anthony o'neil joining us
he is the author
of the number one best-selling book debt
free
degree be sure and check his stuff out
at youtube but he's got a
show called the table that is incredible
new episodes every monday
and you can check them out on youtube
the table
with anthony o'neal all kinds of cool
guests and
conversations like this yeah except i'm
not been allowed on there
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there plus they
offer
unbelievable financial benefits secure
your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america anthony
o'neil ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at
825-5225 have you ever made a dumb
decision with zeros on the end
because you didn't do your research yeah
me too
uh most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions
especially when they're buying a home
but this is a bad idea and when it comes
to real estate market feelings are not
your friend
facts are so check your facts find out
what you can actually afford research
what's trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate agent in
your area never buy a house without the
fax
text house three seven eight nine
that's house 233 789
and we'll help you connect up with an
agent you know that's really what we
should have told that young lady from
provo we should have
that she could get with an agent who
would help her navigate that market
instead of just
bouncing around on websites and zillow
and everything else trying to figure out
what's going on and
and then declaring that trailer homes
are the only thing under 250. yeah
um a good agent can help her navigate
that and go yeah but there are these
little neighborhood over here
and there's you can move out there and
you go 10 miles that way
and they know the nuances of the market
and can help move you in and out of
those and that makes a a big difference
thing is this if you're going to buy a
property and you've been through this a
couple of times and i've
bought a lot of real estate over the
years but
um you know i'm looking at a property
right now uh
a vacation home situation
and uh what i did what i've done is i
have
actually i'm such a nerd i enjoy
the research and so i go to every
neighborhood look at every house start
looking at the square footages start
looking at what drives prices in those
areas
start looking at the square foot price
look at the features and what is it
that's
in that in that market what's different
and what's new
and and just learn the way people think
when they're doing that market because
that's what drives prices
yes and then you start to figure out
okay well
they're paying for prestige in that
neighborhood okay okay in that
neighborhood they're paying for the
access to the beach in that neighborhood
they're paying you know and you can see
what's the different things are moving
around in the market and you you just
begin
but all that comes from options and
options and studying and studying and
studying and studying
so you don't look at three houses and
buy a house you don't go on three dates
and get married right right so you need
to go
and look at some property uh you need
and not just online
because i gotta tell you man some of
these people taking pictures are
really good with their picture-taking
and when you get there you're going was
this the same house
yeah and uh you got to be kidding me
how'd that backyard shrink that much and
so
[Laughter]
you know that camera angle worked on
that one yeah
yeah so it's just like that girl's not
that pretty so there you go
dave that's a good one right there you
know i like that you just get in there
and you go visit the properties
and you begin to get you start to figure
out what's driving the pricing
yes the location the traffic
the school what is it this what's what's
the what's the big draw
that's that's making this property okay
well
what if i move uh you know 25 off of
that
off of that issue and i move over here
well maybe schools aren't important to
you maybe you're retired
yeah you know uh my shih tzu does not
need to go to school
right so i'm pretty good on school
systems i couldn't give a real bless
on where the school system is from my
personal residence
because i'm not gonna have it you know
i'm not gonna be having any kids go to
school there
so uh you know that's not a driver
driving point but so if school's driving
a price up then i'm probably not in that
neighborhood
nope yeah unless there's some other
reason for me to be in there but i mean
that's not my motivator is my point
so you just start to look at things
through that lens and
do do your dad gum research yeah and if
you know you're not good at doing the
research that's why you reach out to one
of our pros and they will
do all the research for you well and
they'll take you around i mean you gotta
you you need to get your arms around
what's happening yes and the pro can
guide you in doing that i don't want
somebody else to do your thinking for
you
exactly but but the uh yeah you need to
you know you need a test drive i mean
same thing with a car you don't just go
buy a car you've never driven
absolutely no i mean never driven that
model now if i've driven that make and
model and everything else and i know the
car inside and out then i don't have to
drive it to buy it i mean i understand
i'm fine just deliver the thing it's
okay but if you've never
driven that kind of you know a pickup
that pickup that particular model
and don't go buy one until you've driven
it i mean that's just not that's common
sense
yeah and yet people get all wired up and
fired up emotionally and jump on stuff
and
start making all these assumptions about
well it's just the way it is in our
world you don't understand you're
you're a boomer you don't get it yeah so
um
but turns out i do
go figure kelly's with us in seattle hi
kelly welcome to the dave ramsey show
hello hey what's up
so my husband and i are in baby step
number two
um we uh
we have a total of three mortgages so we
have the home that we currently live in
um and then we have two rental
properties both with mortgages on them
and one of the homes is older
and um we're trying to debate on whether
or not we
sell that one okay
why did you tell me why did you tell me
it was older does that mean you like
probably wouldn't care as soon as we you
know
it would be like it's not the one you
would keep because it's probably not a
great property over the next 10 years
is that why you told me it's
well as soon as we committed to the baby
steps
and the saving and setting aside we had
the savings in there um
everything that everything started
breaking
that's like the law of financial peace
university as soon as you start the
class your transmission goes out i mean
it's just the way it is
i'm sorry i'm sorry well uh
uh so the question is what's the house
that you're thinking about selling worth
um about 325 000 okay
and what do you owe on it 127 000.
how much debt do you have um
so we are um
we have twenty thousand dollars we owe
on our truck and twenty six
thousand dollars we owe on our tractor
okay
so um yeah since november
first we've so far we've paid off
fifteen thousand dollars that was in
um credit card debt okay the three
hundred fifty thousand dollar old house
where stuff's breaking
all of this discussion aside if you just
put that house in your mind and you go
ten years from now is the ten year now
from now
uh kelly happy with the current kelly
for keeping that house
i don't know it was it was my husband
and i got it
uh i have a lot of emotional attachment
to it
that wasn't what i asked
what i asked is ten years from now are
you gonna be really feeling wise
smart happy because you kept this house
if we stay on track yes okay then i'd
probably keep it and just work your way
through
okay but i mean okay i've owned i've
owned
things that i look out into the future
me and i'm going the future me thinks
the current me
stupid if i don't get rid of this thing
you know i mean you can kind of look at
it and think that right
and that might not be true on this house
and it sounds like it's not so that's
cool
but i mean i look at some of the stuff
and i'm going i'm just gonna throw that
away why have i been storing that
for two years you know that just needs
to leave i need to have a minimalist
moment here and start cleaning out crap
you know because i just we're all pack
rats in our lives and you can do that
with big items and you can do that with
investments and
you know with all kinds of things you
just go just because you've got it
doesn't mean you have to keep it
i agree look into the future and go but
it sounds like
that the future is happy with you for
keeping it so i'm i'm fine with that too
that's an okay answer
then you would keep it and you would go
forward now dave it sounds like she's
happy
keeping it because of the emotional tie
not because of the financial investment
i think she's really tied to this house
emotionally okay well that would be a
mistake then if that's the only reason
but right
i'm guessing too that it's probably i
mean 350 000 house it's not a
it's not a house yeah not a bad house at
all yeah so
uh this is not a it's not a slumlord
here no it's not so
um i'm i'm thinking the thing's got to
be making some money
you know it's i'm just sure she's got
good equity in it too so
yeah yeah i don't know i'm
kind of counting on her right i see to
manage her
emotions and her financial yeah by
looking into the future that was my that
was my
play there i don't know if it worked but
that was my play this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air this is
the dave ramsey show
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage roger is with us hey roger
welcome to the show
hi how how are you better than i deserve
good to have you where do you live
uh san francisco oh wow bit of a trip
over to tennessee
yeah but i definitely have to come out
and try all these fresh cookies that you
kept mentioning on the show
well there they are a pretty good bait
they will lure in lots of people i've
noticed
so you're here to do a debt-free scream
how much have you paid off uh fifty-one
thousand dollars and
uh fifty-one thousand and ninety-two
mm-hmm and how long does that you uh
take me uh 16 months
16 months way to go and uh your range of
income during that time
about 76 000 to 93 000. very good what
do you do for a living
i'm a health health and safety
consultant for our workers compensation
company
oh very good okay so what kind of debt
was the 51
000 yeah so um i had about six thousand
dollars left on my car
um about 7 500 from a debt consolidation
from previous credit cards uh and then
the rest of it actually was all spread
amongst like five other different credit
cards
so um one of the main reasons why i
wanted to come up here and
do this debt free stream is because i
didn't really find a lot of other people
that
didn't have um you know that weren't
working to pay off debt that wasn't any
student loans so
you know i felt a little bit embarrassed
that you know a lot of that wasn't
student loans because everyone else i've
heard had it but
you know i was just a really bad
consumer but it's great to finally own
up to it and you know
finally have it all paid off i love it
well this is the completion of the
healing i love it well congratulations
sir
how old are you roger uh 33 years old
man what was the hardest thing
throughout this process
for me the hardest thing was just saying
no so many of my friends just wanted to
keep enabling me and um
just i'm not the kind of person that
likes to say no um and so
that was just the biggest part um and
then really the other second part thing
was uh
really just trying to build up momentum
and i'm sticking to the budget i think
was the really difficult part
so what happened that caused you to
decide to do this what was the process
uh yeah so i basically had my i've had
it moment
um and so being in san francisco i
actually had the opportunity to
interview for something in los angeles
at this point my finances had kind of
caught up to me and i was kind of
starting to feel the weight of it
um and so instead of shelling out for a
flight i decided to take a bus and then
i said that i would rent a car to
go to the job interview come back and
then take the bus back home
so i took the bus i got to the rental
car but i noticed that in my wallet i
only had
the credit card that i had already maxed
out and so
um going to the credit card company i
knew that they weren't going to accept
that credit card because it's
maxed out and so uh when i got there um
i told them that you know i didn't have
any credit card and
or or any money and like a debit card to
um possibly do the rental and then
and then you know they they swiped it
and then it said denied and so i was
kind of in a pinch and so um
luckily my uber app still had my other
credit card that wasn't maxed out saved
on there
and i was able to do the job interview
and then come back but um
i was just so embarrassed and i
you know i felt like i needed to do a
change and so that night i
um when i got back i added up everything
and i found out just
how much actual consumer debt i had and
i was really scared
and so um you know i had um google
search
you know debt consolidation and yeah you
know like how to get out of debt and
obviously you know dave ramsey shows up
and so
that's how i um started that journey 16
months ago
good for you well done well done
yeah there's um there's a lot of
emotions that are gross
embarrassment might be one of the most
gross ones
i can't stand being i can't especially
when it's my fault
that's just awful yeah and i've been
right exactly in that situation where
you get
you know the card denied and you can't
you can't move around you're stuck
and man that broke feeling and uh
so i i i was traveling a little while
back and we're staying at this really
nice resort
and i walk up the counter and uh my card
had apparently hit the algorithm and
um my debit card had hit the algorithm
for fraud and so the bank had shut it
down
unbeknownst to me so i go up there and i
can't check into this hotel
now i've got plenty of money but that
but that activated
these emotions down inside remember when
i was going
when i was broke and i could you know
and the embarrassment of not being able
to do that and
man i got so mad oh yeah and all it was
was that those
old emotions from from being broke and
being embarrassed were down inside of me
and um i had uh i had to call the banker
back and apologize after i
called her the first time okay so about
my dadgum card getting cut off for no
freaking reason and and they're leaving
me stranded out here so yeah it's the
same thing
that that'll get you going and you had
you definitely had a never again moment
didn't you
definitely yeah very cool so you found
us on go ahead i'm sorry
go ahead dave you're fine okay thank you
dave
[Laughter]
so you walked through all this
embarrassment you paid off all this debt
um how do you feel now like i'm just so
curious about that like
you you have a lot of energy on stage
right now so i'm like how do you feel
what's
next for this young man uh you know it's
still a very surreal feeling
um you know it's um it's really weird
like
i think one of the things that gets to
me sometimes i'll hop in my car start
driving to work
uh and then i just think like i actually
own this whole car
it's hard for me to just embrace that
idea you know like this whole thing
is the reason why i have like a positive
net worth right now you know
so you know instead of knowing that you
know the bank is going to be asking me
for more money you know being upside
down or something like that
but then also the other thing is um it's
very true what you guys mentioned is
that you know it feels like i have a
raise now
because now that i've learned to budget
now i know how to plan for my money
i um i'm not rich obviously but i
definitely feel like
there's a lot more than i can afford now
and um i know that dave you say you know
it you right now you're better than you
deserve but right now i feel like i can
afford what i deserve now and so
that's really like yeah that's how it
feels right now it's a sense of power
that's that's very good good for you i
like that statement we may
we may instill that i can afford what i
deserve
yeah i like that yeah and if you can't
afford it
you don't deserve it
definitely yeah that's good man well
done
yeah well done so the credit cards are
all cut up
mm-hmm will you ever go back in debt oh
no uh i was it was great because i
planned this whole trip with um
with my debit card um and then also i
made sure to go dollar
to get my um my our car rental and i did
it with a debit card so it felt
you know it felt really nice to know
that i was still secure with uh debit
card just like you said yeah when you go
into the nashville
airport with dollar with us endorsing
them they definitely know what's going
on
they got it they got it figured out for
sure there so well done guys
well done man i'm proud of you that's
just beautiful we've got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires
and that's the next chapter in your
story for real and
we're very well done proud of you yeah
uh thanks dave
if you don't mind i'd like to like to
thank my biggest cheerleader
actually so my biggest cheerleader is
about my now fiance monica who
made a trip all the way out here to
nashville with me all right
um it's actually funny because i was
maybe like a year into you know the plan
and i was trying to go um dave ish
instead by
creating a sinking fund to actually save
for her engagement ring
and then when she found out about that
she's like what would uncle dave say and
then
oh like okay i'll i guess i'll just
throw that actually uh
towards my debt and that's the reason
why i was able to get out faster than i
originally planned so i like her
yeah definitely you you teach other
young ladies like yourself
and then you know the biggest thing
about her cheering for me was we were
only together for maybe three or four
months before
i really came out to tell her about how
just how much debt i actually had
and knowing that she was willing to put
off a lot of that honeymoon feeling of
you know spending money you know in the
early goings of a relationship and
her sticking with me through that to you
know where i am now today
i just really want to thank her for you
know not having those fancy dates that
most other people
might usually have so yeah in san
francisco they're not cheap either oh no
well done well done sir proud of you
good work good work all right
roger from san francisco 51 000 paid off
in 16 months making 76-93
it was everything he was normal and now
he's weird count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one i'm dead to go man
way to go that's awesome this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i'm dave ramsey open phones at
is in 825-5225 new york hi brian welcome
to the show
hey good afternoon dave thanks for
giving me some of your time here this
afternoon
sure what's up yeah i got a question for
you
luckily my financial advisor i was
already on a similar mindset as yourself
before i started listening to you my
wife and i
um recently had purchased a home in 2020
and we also had a baby a month prior to
that so
we were already on the debt snowball
method uh we have about a hundred and
nineteen thousand dollars in
well referred to as bad debt uh student
loans
and vehicles and then our home mortgage
is about 137
remaining at the moment so my question
to you is we have about ten thousand
dollars in savings
do you think in you know plus the debt
snowball method
a thousand of that should be going to
savings and nine towards debt
my wife has a little apprehension about
that should we be putting
9010 towards our debt
or should we keep that to the side now
that we have a baby and then the second
tier to that question is
with our tax return coming up now with a
home and a baby
hopefully a good return back should we
also be putting that all towards student
loan debt
i mean absolutely brian uh this is
anthony i
and i understand you know both you and
your wives hesitation
and why but baby step one was not made
and that baby step two was not made to
be
comfortable one and two uh we want you
to be uncomfortable so you can get out
of it
uh quicker and so yes i i was in your
shoes
i didn't have six figures of debt but i
had a lot of debt and i put all of my
savings towards it i put all of the
extra income towards it i even put my
tax return
uh towards it as well i mean what you'll
see is that when you really get gazelle
intense when you really get focused
you all will get out of it much quicker
and get to your baby set three which is
three to six months so
i would absolutely put all of your money
all of your extra money towards it now
let's say something happens to the baby
and y'all you need to pause that that is
totally okay
uh we want you to take care of your
family and protect
uh your family but at the same time
right now if everything is going well
yes attack attack it fiercely and put
all the extra money towards it
what's your household income
uh i would say our household incomes
around 130 to 150.
uh my wife's a teacher and i work in an
outside medical sales so
in the last 12 to 18 months my income's
increased about 30 percent now that i'm
actually in the industry a little bit
longer and i've built a client base
so you know getting back to my initial
comment and about a year and a half ago
we started the debt snowball method with
my financial advisor
then i started listening to you oddly
enough right we had our baby now that i
worked from home
i had serious xm on and a lot of his
mindset aligns with yours we already had
term life insurance
we were already on the death snowball
method um but you know now that i've got
more income
we have more savings which is great so
you said your
total consumer debt on the car and the
uh student loans whatever was was what
119
yes we've got two vehicles and then our
student loan debt combined
yeah what do you owe on the vehicles
the vehicles is about 18 and 15 about 33
to 35 000 between the two of us
okay that's good news all right um
well here's the thing i try to do just
big math
big chunk math i call it and say okay
make 130 heading towards 150
if i pay 60 000 of that towards
debt because i'm unbelievably intense
and focused then i'm done in two years
right and i just look at it that that's
that helps me to get my head around
okay i'm not suggesting that
uh you walk around with a baby and raise
a family with a thousand dollars in the
bank
as your way of life over the next decade
but
as a short-term mechanism to be
all-in to be committed beyond belief
and a little bit of that is what anthony
says is the fear
of not having that money but 10 000 is
not going to help you anyway it's not i
mean
that's a that's a small small emergency
too
uh so you know it'll help more than
it'll help more than not having it but
it's um yeah when you can see that we're
gonna do this we're gonna do this with
great focused intensity and it's gonna
be
24 months and we're going to be done or
it's going to be
19 months and we're going to be done or
whatever the number ends up being
then you can go okay i can hold my
breath that long and then when we don't
have
any payments but a house payment oh my
goodness then you put that emergency
fund in place and i blink
doesn't take time at all yes because
you're used to living on nothing
and you're used to pouring everything on
that debt and you turn and pour it on to
that emergency fund that baby step three
usually goes really fast for people
because they're
just so they've got so much momentum yes
and they're they've been
living on nothing coming off that high
of paying off your debt now you want to
see all that money in your savings
account i mean
it's it's it's amazing yeah that's very
good
very good good job man well done and
congrats on the new baby
zach is in marion illinois hi zach
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave um just had a quick question for
you um
i started listening to you about a month
ago my wife and i are on babysit too
we have about 21 000 in debt that i
should have paid off by
late summer good um but my bigger issue
is is we made the mistake about six
years ago my wife and i bought a
manufactured home
and actually put it on some land that we
owned um
at the time it seemed like a good idea
but now that i'm
a little older realizing that it was
probably a terrible idea
and it's losing value every day i'm in
it so um i just didn't know if i should
move now or stay a little bit longer and
pay it off and then move or what you're
taking that one
might be yeah so would you build on your
land if you got rid of it
i think i would just sell the the land
and the home package deal
and just start fresh yeah okay
all right that's fine well i mean the
bottom line is
is what are you what's the thing worth
today
about 100 including the land right
that's correct what's the land worth
without the thing on it
uh probably 12 to 15 000 okay so this is
an expensive
trailer yes all right about a brand new
and 15
okay yeah so you got like 70
thousand dollars worth okay so ten years
from now that seventy eighty thousand
dollars is not going to be worth 70 or
80 000 agreed
agreed versus if you have the exact same
amount of property in a traditional
home it would go up in value instead of
down in value
agreed yeah that was that's my main
reason for wanting to get out of this
yeah i just know
i realized that so really delaying it or
getting it paid off
just means you're going to lose more
money
so i mean there's no emergency nothing's
on fire
but i'm going to start talking about
having this thing out of my life in the
next 12 14
that months my plan i just wanted to
kind of get your take on it because
like i said i should be on baby step two
this summer and then yeah
i don't have i want any other debt so
yeah absolutely well i mean i
i i'm not a snob this has nothing to do
with
i hate you know trailers or something
like that that's not the point of mobile
homes or manufactured housing whatever
euphemism you want to put on the thing
what i don't like is only things that go
down in value
when i have an alternative to spend very
similar dollars into something that goes
up in value
and so that that's what it comes down to
and so you know people mobile home what
do you hate us
in the mobile home business i don't hate
you i just think your stuff goes down in
value
i mean it's it's pretty simple and so
you know it's
i don't wanna and i'm not gonna tell
people buy stuff that goes down in value
yeah and um and a friend of mine owns a
huge
mobile home business and you still
wouldn't do it even if you pay cash for
it right dude that goes down in value
yeah i mean it goes down in value so why
not pay cash for
you know you know the something that
goes up in value that was very big
where i grew up at in the country like
oh absolutely they're everywhere
everyone me too yeah me too and
so it's not it's not a snobbery thing
it's just a matter of mathematics and
just goes one goes up in value
one goes down in value choose a you know
that's choose the right choice yeah and
that and that's that's what he's doing
that's all he's talking about
yes sir so it's not a matter of we're
angry at someone like that or something
but
you know it's and it's honestly cheaper
to rent
it is than it is for for the thing to go
down in value and pay payments on it
like a car you sleep in this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb cash is king and
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i
am dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five anthony o'neil ramsey
personality is my co-host today
we're taking your calls and your
questions rebecca is with us in johnson
city tennessee hi rebecca how are you
i'm doing good thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
okay my husband and i have paid off
around 70 to 80 000
in debt we have our uh
we have our fund so we we have made it
to step four
good and we're here trying to calculate
and get ready to work our budget up so
we can put
money aside so we were wondering do i
need to make that 15
out of my gross pay or should i be
looking at my net income you're gross
okay so that includes my tcrs my 403
and all that
well i mean that's how you would spend
the 15
in your retirement planning but but
you're just going to we're going to say
what's your annual income in your
household
what is it say again
about a hundred thousand okay so it's
fifteen thousand dollars
okay now how are we going to get there
and the way you would get there is you
first use any matches do you have match
at either place
your your husbands or yours
not much well do you have a match or not
yeah
uh well it's a ten dollars is all these
the 403 v does ten dollars they match it
ten dollars
yeah why why bother okay
my husband's here with me so this is
thomas he's also talking
okay hey thomas
we are both school teachers okay we have
a
we have our tcrs right state retirement
right and we have a school a 403 b
yeah that's a school ten dollars a month
on so
that's the extra comes out right so
you're talking to school board matching
ten dollars a month which is
insignificant
yeah that's an understatement yeah yes
it's insulting as well okay um so all
right so
so um well what we tell you is do match
first
roth second so before i did a 403 b i
would max out both roths
which will get you close to your 15 000.
how old are you guys
uh i'm 53 and she is 46.
yeah okay well you can do if you're over
50 you can do 7
000 and so we're going to do 7 000 for
you and 6 for her
so that's 13 of the 15 and so you only
need to be putting about 2
000 over into one of your 403 b's and
put that in good mutual funds
annually and that's how we get there
we're going to go raw
match first roth second traditional
third
is the is the way we work our way down
through the 15 000 to get there and so
we're going to do two roth individual
roth iras in good mutual funds
with a smart vester pro sit down and get
that started
and then above that set up about you
know set up a couple hundred bucks a
month going into your
403 b out of one or both of your checks
100 bucks each i don't care
what it doesn't matter and pick out a
good mutual fund or mutual
a single mutual fund be fine on that
small amount yeah
in that 403 b and get going and
you know 403 b's are they are
uh notorious for not having great
investment options in them so
be poking around and searching in it a
lot of them have a bunch of junk
insurance products in them instead of
actual investments
and so um you got to really look and
poke around figure out what your
possible options are but we're looking
for good mutual funds growth stock
mutual funds that have long track
records
and certainly the same thing for your
roth iras that we're talking about
funding and that's how you calculate it
and then also too dave now that's for
someone who has like a stable
uh income someone like yourself and
myself probably more so like me
um whose income is is fluctuating some
seasons i have highs some scenes i have
low i tend to do monthly so whatever i'm
getting gross
monthly then i'll do 15 percent of that
until i max out all my other
retirements yeah you can set a a
baseline
on an emergency i mean on an automatic
draft if you want to
yes and then you can just add manually
to it to hit your monthly
yes 15 if you're doing that if you got
the if you got some volatility in the
income
yes a couple teachers that's superbly
predictable
yeah i mean you'll be able to figure out
exactly what it is and you know we're
dealing with a hundred thousand dollars
we're doing
fifteen thousand dollars and we just
figure out what that is and lay it out
that way but it sounds like each of you
do a roth plus
maybe a hundred bucks each in your in
your 403 b that'd be like 2 400 a year
and um that would get you there yes
that's your 15 000.
that's what we're after brandon is with
us brandon is in yakima
washington hi brandon welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave nice to meet you you too how can
we help
well i was one of the geniuses that
thought it was a good idea to
take out a loan against my 401k to pay
off the higher interest credit card debt
okay um and i'm currently 31
and i wanted to know if um also this
would be the largest debt i currently
have
um and but due to the loss of the gains
that i would have gotten
uh i was wondering would it be better to
move this debt up on the list
and start paying it back quicker to
regain those losses
now faster due to the type of debt it is
yeah now
how much how much do you own no uh 12
000 okay and how much other data have
you got
i have about thirty six
thousand thirty six to forty thousand
until total that's including my student
loans as well
okay and what's your household income
uh my net is around
um down through around 3 600 a month
so you're making what 60 grand
here um i think i think it's i think
it's closer to
54.55 okay all right that's cool good
all right so you're making 55 how fast
you're going to pay 36 off yes
i'm sorry could you repeat that you're
making 55 how fast are you going to pay
36 000
with a debt off uh according to the baby
steps app
uh five years or six years sorry
no no no you failed
right um failed in the use of the baby
steps app yeah uh
so here's the thing eighteen thousand a
year yeah will be done in two years
there you go that's 1500 a month
and you got to get in complete attack
mode yeah what you plugged into the baby
steps app was minimum payments
exactly and no extra payments on your
debt right yeah i mean if you keep
paying minimum payments and you get out
in five years i'd be surprised
but you need to be paying oh you need to
come out pocket 1500 bucks a month in
payments
and brandon you're single you're young
i'm gonna say it man man up go get you
an extra job
you could be out of this thing about a
year year and a half if you really want
to get out of debt
yeah yeah that would be good that would
even be better
yes and the point being that if it's a
very short period of time
then the loss of gains on your 401k loan
are not going to be significant because
you're not going to be out of it that
long
you're going to get there really really
fast but you need to be done in two
years and then
that makes your question less
pertinent because you're not going to be
out of the investments for very long
but turn up the heap baby let's go this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend blinds.com
is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
becky is with us in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
hi becky welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi gentlemen thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um so my husband and i
are currently in baby step number two
we've paid off about eleven thousand of
our forty two thousand dollar debt since
august
um we're planning to make a move from
pennsylvania to north carolina in july
and my question is should we halt baby
step two
or put money aside through the budget
you're going to have to it's not halt
baby step two it's just stop
everything and pile up cash for the move
yeah okay because we do plan on selling
our house here to make a profit on there
and then renting when we go down there
until we can make a
you know substantial down payment so i
didn't know if we should use some of the
profit from the house or
well when you sell your home and you
make the move
then that's got that gives you the cash
to pay off all the debt right
correct yeah you're debt-free then and
you go on and you restart your baby
steps when you land in north carolina
but you're probably going to need some
cash to make this move and
we've got to get the house sold correct
and becky here's here's a key thing too
i really want you to do is on baby step
2 i want you to hear what dad
dave said he said pause you know stack
up cash
now for me that means budget do the
research
identify how much money you need so if
you need let's say for an example 10
grand to make the move
once you get to 10 grand go ahead and go
back on baby set number two and just
start
attacking that debt because you have the
cash stacked away
yeah and then of course when the house
sells you write a check and pay off
everything so
that's a good move that's fun good for
you guys uh brian is with us brian's in
memphis hi brian welcome to the dave
ramsey show
yes sir uh me and my wife were blessed
enough to find your program back in
august
and uh somehow i talked to her on board
and
we're on baby step two rocking and
rolling we've gotten rid of sixty six
thousand
and wow that's august wow good for you
man
yeah we're out for blood well done
yes uh my next question is about we
ended up
with two mortgages um we outgrew a home
bought a home before we sold our other
home and
where i'm at with it is a whole 43
000 on the home and we tried to sell it
the realtor
said it was worth about 90. we had it on
the market for about eight months
with zero interest in buying and uh
overwhelming interest in renting it
so we kind of just got tired of carrying
the house and decided to rent it
um but our renters are getting ready to
leave and
my next question is how gazelle intense
should i be on getting rid of this thing
without just doing something stupid as
far as
you know putting a ninety thousand
dollar home up yourself for 43 000
just to get rid of it well i wouldn't do
that i wouldn't do that you're not being
foreclosed on there's no reason to give
it away
so you have you have one of two problems
or or both
um your house was priced too high or
your realtor's a doofus
definitely number two is true
[Laughter]
okay yeah which may mean that the house
is priced too high too i don't know i
mean you got
zero interest of any kind i'm
thinking it's not it's not it may not be
a 90 000 house it might be an 80 000
house but we know it's not a 43 000
house okay
so uh jump online at daveramsey.com and
get in touch with one of our elps for
real estate
they're high octane high protein and
they're gonna shoot you straight
one of the ways that a realtor a real
estate agent is an
excellent real estate agent and moves a
lot of volume is
they don't take listings
that are overpriced they take listings
that are priced to sell
not to give away but they're priced
properly
and they don't the seller doesn't get to
decide that in the sense that
you you get to decide it it's your house
but i mean you you look at
actual statistical evidence called a
comparative market analysis an appraisal
on the property that the real estate
agent does showing you comps in the area
and you look at that and go this house
does not need to be listed at 90. it
needs to be listed at 82.5
and then it'll move or whatever it is i
don't know
but i think that's what's happened to
you probably you could be just a little
bit off and just enough off that you ran
off
because what happens when people get
give give you the eye roll
when they see your price right and but i
don't know i don't think you need to
give it away
i i would just start fresh with a good
real estate agent and get good
information and let's price it right
and the spring's coming yeah and it's
going to be a great it's going to be a
great spring real estate's
hopping man it really is i i'm doing i'm
doing the same thing
that's that's what i would do dave good
cool i love it
alex is with us in college station
texas aggieland what's up alex
hey dave hey um just a quick question
so my wife and i will be definitely by
the end of the year
um so it's a little bit further thinking
but i i kind of overthink things
um but after we get debt free
we are our next one is to be saving for
a house
good but that's not looking like for
another about four years
um while she gets through school and
while she's able to
um get her degree in teaching and become
a teacher and then we're looking to buy
after that just in case we
move um i have a really flexible job
um and so we're just looking to see what
would be best
should we invest start investing some
will look 25
24 yes um or should we hold off
and just pile up money for a down
payment no no you're too young and
you're waiting for four years i don't
want you to go four years without
investing alex
now what you can do invest 15 and while
you're investing 15
going ahead and start saving a little
bit now once you all
find where you are where you are um i
don't have a problem with you pausing a
little bit to save up aggressively for
a down payment but right now i want you
to take advantage of your age of this
season
invest the 15 you can start saving some
extra on the side
and then when you all get there it's
about 30 find your your home your city
then you can pause to aggressively go
after your down payment but please take
advantage of your age and time
and investing right now yeah exactly
that's exactly that's well done
so what i would do you know alex that is
follow that plan but just
look out there a little bit and say okay
today it's four years
but a couple of years from now you look
at me okay it's two years
and we're kind of thinking by then we
want to be over in x or y
city and you start really kind of
dialing in your details and you go okay
two years out i might stop and pile up
cash and get ready for my down payment
at that point
but right now i'm with anthony let's get
started on the investing you've got
plenty of time here
and you can always start and stop and
that kind of stuff if you need to you
may be able to save your down payment
beyond the 15
and never stop it that's a possibility
too i like that
and uh you know if you just keep working
on it and pushing along now
obviously we're doing this while she's
in school he's working so we're on a
pretty tight budget my guess is
probably a lot of room in this but
that's not a bad plan at all well done
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five thank you for joining us america
now how many of you guys are stressed
out or you're hurting
because your retirement savings took a
major hit last year
well it only took a major hit last year
if you took it out at exactly the wrong
time
see yeah maybe you're super close to
retiring and you're wondering if you
should work a few more years
maybe you're trying to figure out this
overall situation
and say i don't know what to do with my
investing so you need a pro
in your corner to coach you and it's not
to tell you what to do
i don't do what the elp or the smart mr
pro tells me what to do
i learn from them and then i make a
decision
now they'll have a suggestion probably
but this is not a
my guy tells me what to do with my money
and i blindly follow my guy you don't do
that
so if you want to learn to invest or
you've got questions about your
retirement text
invest to 33789
find an investment pro in your area
never again face a global crisis
alone text invest
to seven 33 nine
invest two thirty three seven eight
nine and david i want to say that sutu
to america when
you do that text the word about you're
gonna get like three to five
smart vesters from us who are highly
qualified individuals
but let me say this interview all five
of them and see who works best for you
and your family
yeah maybe just personality yeah what do
you connect up with and
and what you're always looking for with
financial people whatever kind of
financial people it is
it's the heart of a teacher you're
always looking for someone that's
teaching you
and you'll know you've got someone with
the heart of a teacher because you don't
feel slimed
you don't feel sold you've
learned something every time you have a
conversation with yes and that's what
you want to do you want to be around
people
teaching you something so that you can
make better decisions with
your money this is how this works this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two
kyle and caitland are on the line in
reno nevada it says
on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you thank you sir thank you well
done how much have you paid off
about 75 000. how long did this take you
16 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
um about 97 to 106. good what do you
guys do for a living
i am a second grade teacher and i'm a
wildland firefighter
awesome blm wow what a year you guys
have had
and uh yeah man covet and fires and
everything else huh
so uh 75 000 worth of what kind of debt
um that was a truck um and then two
student loans and some medical bills so
you're kind of normal
yeah yeah what happened what got you
started
um well we were doing our taxes and we
realized
how much money we made and um that if we
actually buckled down it would take us
no time to get rid of our debt
and before we started we were doing dave
ish and we were already putting money
away
but we weren't really attacking our big
debts yet
and we kind of just wanted to be in
control of where our money went and so
we started to do our budgeting and got
our money on track
and then and so you just basically did
the budget and took off huh
yeah yeah dave i've been listening to
for a little bit here and there and when
she said davish i mean we were
paying more towards the loans but we
weren't like doing
full gazelle intense and when i sat down
to our taxes and i was like hey love
we could we could do this pretty darn
quick if we just uh
sit down and go to the grind for it
so right before he asks you to do
something difficult does he always call
you love caitlin
he knows how to do it i
love it i love it hey throughout this
journey you guys i i gotta ask
um you know what was one of the hardest
things you know
going throughout this process you know
and seeing your taxes like but after
that
what was the most difficult part of
getting out of debt
um i think it would just be staying on
track i mean
you see others doing the things that you
want to do
or you know going out to eat and and
just holding
each other accountable and keeping goals
in mind
because we saw you know we saw the end
goal and so we had to just keep
reminding ourselves of that and not
trying to live like everybody else was
living and i think uh
one of the things that i had i like
doing a lot of projects yeah and we were
kind of on a
newer house to us when we moved up here
and from flagstaff arizona and
a lot of yard work needed to be done and
i'm a big project guy so
i definitely had to hold off my projects
and uh do a lot of drawing and sketching
of what i wanted to do
after we paid everything off yeah yeah
that's good
well it gives you a reason to push on
through then yeah that's cool yep
exactly
that's good very good so how does it
feel now that you're free
oh man it feels great i mean it's just
nice to
oh now that we're on four we got through
three four five and six i mean
money's going to the kids college uh
putting the 15
in and going towards the house what we
have left and
just being able to go out and do some
things that we weren't able to do before
amen wow that's cool so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
now that you did it what is the big
way somebody listening okay i got 75
000. i want to do that in 16 months
how you do it um well just
be on the same page and even when you're
not on the same page just communicate
about it there were definitely times
that we
you know disagreed or got on each
other's nerves but we at least talked
through
everything and we held each other
accountable like we already said
um but two of the biggest things is
first of all the budget and and sticking
to it and really knowing
why we have money going where it's going
um
and then celebrating small milestones so
along the way we kind of broke up our
our chunk of budget into four pieces
and every time we hit one of those
pieces we had something to celebrate
and it kind of kept this going those
celebrations we had honestly
uh it was nice it was before coveted but
when we it came down to it
we had one celebration we were going to
go do a little staycation and
it didn't end up happening it just
didn't uh fall in the books and planning
and so that
extra money we were going to spend on
that went back to the debt boom here we
go
yeah game on yeah yeah that's a big deal
so what's next
i mean you guys are already investing
you guys are already investing into your
kids future
um what's next how do you celebrate this
you know now that now that you can take
your feet off of the pedal
um how do you really enjoy it well right
now we're trying to save for a uh
newer suburban and man vehicles are
expensive
yes they are that's the truth especially
suburbans
and when you actually pay for them you
realize that more don't you
yes yeah like i've been looking i've
just been keeping my eye on
looking for the right deals i'm always
shopping around and
man it is impressive how expensive they
are
well great job you guys great job we're
very proud of you
and the kiddos have been involved what
are their names and ages
um we have mia and emilyn and they
are almost five they're twin girls and
then we have
watson and he is almost nine months well
he's a big help
yes yeah you know it
i love it well they're cute we got a
picture of them popping up on youtube
here so we're seeing them this beautiful
family well done you guys
very very well done excellent excellent
job
so all right we got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires and uh kyle caitlin
mia emilyn and you too watson 75
000 paid off in 16 months making 97
97-106 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
ah that's how it's done right there
man wow that's how that's powerful
that is good job you guys great job you
guys
open phones at triple eight eight two
five 825-5225
thomas is in dallas hey thomas how can
we help you today hey
hey dave how are you doing great what's
up
um i just want to say this is an honor i
mean me and my mom been listening to you
for so long
and we also learned about you in school
now
i'm 17 i've been trading stocks since i
was in
about seventh grade i've been profitable
the last two years it took me about four
years
but i'm going off to college pretty soon
to play baseball
on an athletic scholarship and i don't
think i'm gonna have time to trade
stocks uh to make my money
and i've came up with the conclusion
that i should open up a roth ira
and just start feeding that monthly
while i'm in college and just have that
grow
and pick individual stocks and and uh
not so much conservative stuff because i
am on like the younger side and i still
have time to grow my money
um but i was just gonna ask if that was
a smarter way to uh
to go about it when i'm in college it's
just putting my money in my roth and
just having to go for me over the four
years all right man i'm gonna jump in
before dave jumps in man i i like i like
you young man yeah i can tell you're
really thinking about
thinking about the future there's two
things i'm gonna say one thing
i i think investing into a growth stock
mutual fund covered by ira is a great
option i do not want you to do
individual stocks when i know you've
been doing individual stocks coming up
to now
but i want you to trust the growth stop
mutual fund but before
you you you really jump into that i
really want you to step back
and just really make sure that you
understand you're the number one
investment
i get it this younger generation really
wants to get into the money
really want to see wealth that's great
but the number one asset that you have
is your mind it is you
okay then it's your money which is your
tool but for yourself
make sure that you're graduating debt
free sounds like you will but then make
sure you really understand your why
behind life
you know where are you going in the
future and then once you really have
yourself established and you've invested
into yourself
then yes we can start looking into the
money but the ira
gross up mutual fund perfect route for
you at this at this age
and guaranteed where you're going you'll
be a millionaire before you even turn 45
50 years old
yeah thomas i don't buy single stocks
i've been doing it a long time
and um 78 of the day traders lose money
that's 8 out of ten those are not good
odds son
stop that this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 11 28
and 30 come to me all who labor and
are heavy laden and i will give you rest
take my yoke upon you and
learn from me for i'm gentle and lowly
in heart and you will find
rest for your souls for my yoke is easy
and my burden is life
martin luther king jr said if you can't
fly then run
if you can't run then walk if you can't
walk
then crawl but whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
so anthony i saw a better mlk quote
that's
one of my favorites i use that one all
the time but i hadn't seen the one that
you
posted on your instagram and i just saw
it a while ago when i was thumbing
through here let me see if i can find it
you never memorize it but there it is
uh nope that's not it there's
mlk quotes all over instagram what am i
thinking of course there is that
that one i just did is on there you saw
my when i just posted you posted it
earlier this morning i think
yeah let us not seek to satisfy our
thirst for freedom by drinking from the
cup of bitterness and hatred
that's it yes and um
strength to love i guess that came from
that probably yes yeah
because that book is all about his
uh passive approach non-violent
approach to protesting yes and um
into anything for that matter he uh uh
was a devout pacifist and it's very
interesting read if you've not read that
book folks i strongly recommend it
yes but the strength to love it's
powerful
and for somebody like me that tends to
just i mean i get
i get i'm passionate i get fired up i
just bust something in the nose you know
and for somebody like me it's good to
read something like that to offset
some of that and go okay you need to
calm your butt down
[Laughter]
that's me dave too i needed it yeah it
was a great book just to just to remind
me that you can have strength but how do
we turn that into love
in a loving kind way and at the end of
the day love speaks louder than hatred
and then
and then violence so there you go that's
good there you go
good stuff mlk day open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five anthony o'neil ramsey
personality is
my co-host today uh looks like alicia is
next in
omaha nebraska hi alicia how are you
hello good how are you great how can we
help
so i just finished my master's degree
congratulations
and my husband and i thank you um we
were debating
possibly refinancing our house and being
a cash out to pay off our student loans
no no no no no no no
no no no no how what um how many how
much are you student loans
uh alicia um they're about 50 000
and we have 90 to 95 000
in equity in our house cool i'm not
worried about the equity i don't want
you to do that what shows uh household
income
i'm 65 a year okay what's your master's
degree in
um to be a certified nurse midwife
okay so you haven't started that career
yet no
no i just graduated about a month ago oh
okay
okay so but so we're talking really
you've primarily been working on your
education he's primarily been the
breadwinner is that correct
no you just stay at home dad i work
full-time as a nurse
oh okay so do you anticipate your income
going up as a result of this masters
yes um it should go up to about 90. okay
okay that's good news okay yeah what i
would do
is just exactly what anthony said i'm
just going to roll up my sleeves and i'm
going to get rid of these student loans
here's the thing
if you became permanently disabled the
student loans are forgiven
if you pass away the student loans are
forgiven
none of those are true if you go borrow
on your house
to pay them off and
the it's a good thing to just work
through and be done with this debt and
not do damage
when you move debt over onto your house
you feel like you did
something and the debt just stays there
instead of getting it reduced and your
overall net worth going up as a result
so the great news is your income is
getting ready to go up 30 something
percent
and uh i'm gonna use all of that and any
other money i can squeeze out of this
budget
yeah and i'm gonna get rid of student
loan in about 18 months so aka
and and and a different way of saying it
when you get your raise
you don't have a raise you know you
still live there you go
you know when you when you get you raise
when you get the income it's not yours
it's going all towards that debt
and you're going to live that lifestyle
and live with that mindset
until you pay it all off trust me you do
not want to put that over to your house
yeah because it's going to hang around
forever that way yeah
open phones at eight two five five
two two five christiana is with us in
houston texas hi christiana how are you
i'm fine how are you mr ramsey better
than i deserve what's up
yes my husband and i we are trying to
decide what to do with a chunk of
money that we are that we are projecting
to get
um we think that we can have we have 66
000
left on our mortgage that's the only
debt that we have and
we believe that we can have that paid
off by the end of 2022
um and so we were wondering if the money
that will be coming in up until that
point to pay off the home if we should
go ahead and pay off our house or if we
should take that money and do something
else with it
and that is something we're not sure we
don't know what would be wiser
how much are you expecting
we're expecting uh
we're expecting probably a hundred
thousand dollars over the course of the
next two years
i'm sure you could be debt-free by the
end of the year right
we no no over the course of two years i
know i think we'll have 50 000 this year
and then 50 000 next year but you only
owe 66
right what's your household income uh
it's just my husband's income so it's 90
90 000. yeah so y'all could be debt free
by the end of the year
if you get 50 000 and you add another
what sixteen thousand on top of that
you're debt-free right uh
not sure didn't you say 66 was your
mortgage
yes okay 60 if you get 50 and throw it
out that leaves 16
000 right right and if you were to cash
flow the 16 000 out of your budget
in 12 months that's a little more than a
thousand dollars a month you'd be
i have the house paid for but if we're
off a little bit i mean we'll call it 14
months right
right i mean whatever whatever fits in
the budget but that
the answer is wherever you are on the
baby steps is where you throw
all money and where you are is four five
and six and four is fifteen percent of
your income going into retirement i'm
assuming you're doing that correct
already done
good you have children you're saving for
college
that's correct no okay so we skip five
then any other money that comes we throw
it at six
until the house is done when the house
is done then we can move on and we're at
baby step seven at that point
max out all retirement and the point
there is just to become very wealthy and
outrageously generous
and live and give like no one else
because that's what you've done you've
done a great job by the way
absolutely this is absolutely fabulous
yeah but
if i'm in your shoes i i mean i'm seeing
i can see it it's right there it's only
66 000 i'm just gonna pop that thing man
i'm gonna hit it in the head and kill it
yeah just get it done get it done get it
done dave you want to give me a bonus of
a hundred thousand
no no anthony
your your raise your race is just like
mine
your raise works exactly like my raise
works i mean hey it's effective when you
are
you're right you are absolutely that's
hey i was trying to be effective right
there and ask the question
no but it was just random just a random
lightning bolt right here in front of 17
million people
oh that's fun i will give you a hundred
thousand dollars as soon as you saw a
hundred thousand them books hey man
listen
that's kind of built into your plan
you'll probably make a little more than
that
that's good i'm grateful
so people we need a hundred thousand of
you to buy debt-free degree because
anthony wants a raise amen hallelujah
there we go
thank you jesus you have a worship
service right at the end of the show yes
yes that's amazing that's neat though
make a 90 and get a hundred thousand oh
it's over two years ago it gets fifty
thousand dollar bonus yeah i mean
that bonuses some people sound serious
well yeah you know
for real she's blessed more than i've
made in a lot of my years i know that
wow very very impressive yeah her bonus
is more than i was making as a youth
pastor
oh that gets me upset yeah you well
youth pastors are
renowned for their income yes yeah oh
man that's a tough job man it really is
you have teenagers and no pay
yes yeah it's a tough job oh i don't
miss it i mean i miss it but i don't
miss it
you said that out loud you were thinking
that and you let it come out of your
mouth
i don't believe you did that oh
i put this hour today ramsey showing the
books thanks to james childs and kelly
daniels in the booth
taking care of business back there
making sure this show works i'm dave
ramsey that's anthony o'neil we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
you